المستمره في عده مواقع هنا في مدينه
انطاكيا في هذا الموقع الذي وصلناه بعد
وصولنا الى مدينه انطاكيا بعد حدوث
الزلزال تقريبا العمليات البحث والانقاذ
ما زالت مستمره لكن تم التاكد من عدم وجود
اي اشخاص تحت الانقاض قبل قليل تم حضور او
حضر الى هنا فريق برازيلي معه اجهزه
متقدمه اجهزه قياس نبضات الصوت او استشعار
الصوت فحص كل هذه المبنى ثلاث مباني التي
عفوا خلف هذا المبنى وتم التاكد من عدم
وجود اي اشخاص تحت الانقاض واخبر فرق
الانقاذ التركيه بهذا الوضع لكن اخبرهم ان
هذا المبنى خطر وعليهم هدم هذا المبنى لكن
كان هناك حريق في هذا المبنى لذلك
الجرافه هنا وفرق الانقاذ يقومون بهدم
المبنى ومن ثم بهدم بعض اجزاء ثم اطفاء
الحريق حسب ما علمنا من صاحب المحل هذا
المبنى ربما كان فيه مواد قابله للاشتعال
ربما لم اعلم بالضبط ما هي نوعيه هذه
المواد لكن كان يتحدث عن هناك مواد قبل
الاشتياق اضافه الى
منتجات ورقيه وبالتالي ادت الى هذا الحريق
بعد انهيار المبنى نتيجه الزلزال الذي وقع
مساء امس كون اليوم دخلنا في يوم جديد
مساء الاثنين في انطاكيا نعم نعم نحن
متواصلون في العمل لذلك
مساء الاثنين لذلك
عمليات
الهدم هذا المبنى ستتواصل بحسب ما اوصى
الفريق البرازيلي الذي وصل قبل قليل وايضا
هذا هو الشخص ايضا هو الذي يرتدي الاصفر
لا ليس من الفريق البرازيل الفريق
البرازيلي ليس في الموقع الان لكن بالعموم
هذا المبنى يعني هو عينه او هو
يلخص حال المباني المتصدعه في مدينه
انطاكيا هذه المدينه
تحتوي وبقيه المناطق للسقوط
نعم بالضبط
كل المباني الاله للسقوط هنا في انطاكيا
صدر قرار بهدمها
واستعدادا لعمليه اعاده الاعمار لكن مع
الاسف اتى هذا الزلزال
ليؤدي او نتيجه هذا الزلزال كانت تهدم بعض
المباني التي كانت متصدعه
وادت علمنا الى وقوع ثلاثه وفيات ومئتان
وثلاثه عشر جريحا بحسب الاحصائيه الرسميه
التركيه طبعا تم نقل بعض الجرحى الى مشافي
اضنه والبعض الاخر يعالجون هنا في المشافي
الميدانيه المشافي التي تم اخلائها
كاجراءات ضمن الاجراءات الاحترازيه عاده
العمل كمشفى اسكندرون ومشفى المشافي في
اضنه وبالتالي
العمل في مستشفى الاسكندراني وفي الولايات
المجاوره نعم نعم
نعم
بالضبط طيب زيدان ايضا اود الحديث عن نقطه
مهمه جدا ارجع بك قليلا الى الوراء يعني
قبل قليل تحدث الينا الصحفي محمد العبد
الله عن ان هنالك اجراءات كانت تجري في
اسطنبول حول عمليه المسح الضوئي للمنازل
التي لم تتعرض للهدم اود ان اسالك ما قبل
هذا الزلزال هل تمت عمليات مسح ضوئي
للمنازل في ولايه هاتاي
يعني بشكل عام هذه العمليات تتم بطلب من
اصحاب البناء حتى اليوم في اسطنبول
البلديه بلديه اسطنبول لا تقوم بمسح كل
الابنيه انما الاشخاص الذين يريدون مسح
الابنيه او فحص الابنيه يتقدمون بطلب
للسلطات او تحديدا للبلديات المحليه لترسل
فرق مختصه وتقوم بعمليات الفحص هذا
الاجراء متبع في كل البلديات في كل
الولايات لذلك لا يوجد مسح شامل الا اذا
كان هناك هزات ارتداديه مثلا في اسطنبول
في عام 2019 كان هناك زلزال بعد الزلزال
كان هناك عده مباني متضرره في منطقه وهي
المنطقه التي تعرضت لضرر اكثر من غيرها
لذلك قامت البلديات باجراء فحص شامل لكل
المباني في تلك المنطقه وحددت المباني
الغير قابله للسكن وامرت بهدمها بالتالي
هذه العمليات تتم بشكل فردي في حال لم يكن
هناك اي داعي مثلا زلازل ان كانت خفيفه او
شديده في الحالات العاديه يمكن لاي شخص
صاحب بناء ان يتقدم بطلب ومن ثم ترسل
السلطات المحليه البلديه الفرق المختصه
لفحص المبنى الا في حالات الزلازل تقوم
البلديات وفرق
مهندسين مختصين بعمليات المسح لكل المباني
والتاكد من سلامه هذه المباني ان كانت
مطابقه للشروط
الموضوع من قبل الحكومه فيما يخص الزلازل
او لا نعم هل هناك